(school bell ringing)
- Happy Friday Crete leaders!
I'd like to first thank everyone
for an awesome week back.
I've seen some amazing things.
Not only are students embodying
the Crete core values,
but I saw rockets being made
and launching in the steam class.
I saw critical thinking and reasoning
going on in the chess class.
And I saw students
dancing their hearts out
in the dance class.
So great job during enrichment.
Great job this first week back.
Keep it up and keep embodying
the Crete core values.
I hope you all have a wonderful week.
I will see you on the yard.
And as always, cheerio.
- What's six times four?
24.
All right?
- One.
Good.
Can you show me now?
You have to test brands.
- How do you say that word again?
- Perserverence.
- What's the next one?
- Respect.
- And what's our last one?
- Vision.
- You are dismissed.
- Crete Academy is a
non-profit charter school
serving students pre-K through sixth grade
in South Los Angeles who are experiencing
homelessness and extreme poverty.
Of the 187 students we are 20% special ed.
We are 85 percent free and reduced lunch,
meaning living below the poverty line.
And we are 30 percent
homeless, meaning students
living in shelters, motels, hotels,
and double and tripled
up with family members.
I decided to open this school 15 years ago
when I was volunteering
as a freshman in college
downtown on Skid Row.
And seeing thousands and
thousands of people living
in boxes and under tarps
and in sleeping bags.
I knew then that I wanted to do something,
and I felt that the answer
was a good education.
And creating a space where
these unique children,
because they are unique
in their situations,
could come and thrive.
I chose to start this
school in South Central
because it's known for violence,
high poverty rates, and low
educational attainment rates.
Kids who come through
those doors every day
in these public schools
are lacking basic needs.
And I want to see that change.
- In my old school all
the classrooms were dirty.
There was holes in the walls.
And they didn't really care for us.
Most of the kids got in fights a lot.
- At my old school I was
just getting in trouble
just for doing a lot of
weird stuff and hanging
around with the wrong people.
- Some kids were getting all over me
and one of the staff was just watching,
and I was right in front
of her and she did nothing.
This school has really helped me
get through so many tough times.
- [Je'ky] They have a lot of smart people
that make smart choices,
and I hang around with them now.
- [Naya] This school is
like my dream school.
- Good morning.
Come on.
- [Camilla] Without transportation many
of the kids would not go to school.
So one of the things that we provide
at our school that's critical
to our students' success
and overall family support
is our transportation.
We transport 59 students
every day to school
using two shuttle buses that
each take on two routes.
So starting at 5:30.
By providing transportation
we're alleviating
some of the burden on our families
and really creating more opportunity
for them to have one less
thing to worry about.
- Pound, we pounding this morning?
Pew.
You want breakfast?
- [Camilla] When a student first arrives
in the morning at Crete,
they're greeted by our Dean of Students
who usually stands at the front gate.
And, majority, 90 percent of the students
will come and get breakfast.
- [Woman] Good morning.
So how's your day today?
- Good.
- You good?
That's all I want to know.
- [Camilla] We first of all understand
that there are basic
needs that must be met
before we can educate our kids.
Before we put math or
science or social studies,
before you, we want to
make sure that your mind,
your body, and everything else is intact.
So we offer three meals a day.
We offer mental health resources through
our wellness program so on-site
social workers full time.
All the things that you would need
just to be a healthy human.
- I didn't have a car the first
year that Crete opened up.
But the school made sure my kids were
on the shuttle and they never
missed school because of that.
I'm a single mom.
I was married for seven years,
and I left due to domestic violence.
Being in the shelter and being
in this space in my life
where I'm currently homeless,
it kind of eases you know,
my thinking process like,
OK, my kids are safe.
I don't have to worry about that.
Now let me go and try to
do this, try to do that.
It takes the stress off a bit
knowing that my kids are okay.
- [Camilla] I've always
wanted it to be more
than just a school, and I'm
proud and excited for where
we're at, but there's so
much more that I want to do.
The highlight of working here
is always seeing the kids smile.
I know every kids' story.
I get to know them very
deeply and intimately.
I know their family stories.
And so to know where they're coming from
and what they've been
through, and to see them
run around on the playground, or you know
show me their book report or
their science fair project,
that's what gets me every day.
Every time, it's what
wakes me up in the morning.
Is to see that despite
those circumstances,
despite where you came from
and what you might be going through now,
you can smile.
There's hope.
(orchestral music)